[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild dann kommt dieser Bursche zu uns
und bringt meine Tochter
um da ist jemand der bei dir ein und
ausgeht den du fast jeden Tag siehst der
mit deinen Liebsten befreundet ist und
plötzlich dreht dieser Mensch durch und
wird zum irren Messer
das ist unser Fall heute ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
hallo die Rede ist heute von einem
jungen Mann namens Lon und während wir
hier über seinen Fall sprechen sitzt er
in einem Gefängnis in Bayern
wahrscheinlich noch rund 7 Jahre lang
wenn Leon K seine Haftstrafe verbüß hat
wird das Verfahren neu aufgerollt um zu
prüfen ob er auf freien Fuß kommen kann
weil Lon K aber auch eine psychische
Störung attestiert wurde soll zunächst
auf unbestimmte Zeit in einer
Psychiatrie untergebracht werden wer
also ist dieser Leon bildreporterin Lena
Zander führt uns in den Fall ein sie hat
auch das Gerichtsverfahren begleitet
Leon K ist ein Junge der aus schwierigen
Verhältnissen gekommen ist seine Eltern
waren getrennt seine beiden Schwestern
lebten bei der Mutter er lebte bei
seinem Vater der Vater soll ein
Drogenproblem gehabt haben auch häufiger
Alkohol getrunken haben und Lon K war
ein wenig schwierig er hat selbst
getrunken er hat auch Drogen genommen er
hat seine Schule abgebrochen später
versucht den Abschluss nachzumachen aber
er war verliebt seit 2015 war er in der
Beziehung mit Sophia und Sophia kam aus
einem ganz normalen bürgerlichen
Stadtteil in München aus Neuhausen
Sophia kam aus einer italienischen
Familie sie hatte drei Geschwister ihre
Eltern hatten ein italienisches
Restaurant und er fand auch gut
Familienanschluss
er war häufiger bei der Familie zu Hause
die waren gemeinsam im Urlaub zum
Abendessen war er dort die Mutter hat es
mal so beschrieben er gehörte zur
Familie die Gegend in der die Familie
wohnt ist wirklich gut bürgerlich in
unmittelbarer Umgebung sind nette
Restaurants ein Sportplatz eine
Grundschule und ein Gymnasium Unigebäude
und auch eine Klinik und im übrigen kann
ich mich ganz gut reinfühlen in so eine
Familie meine Kinder sind z.B 16 und 19
und wir hatten auch lange Zeit z.B immer
wieder die Freundin meines Sohnes zu
Gast man wird füreinander zu
Bezugspersonen obwohl man das ja nicht
direkt sich irgendwie selber ausgesucht
hat und bei vier Kindern muss es ja oft
ein munteres ein und aus bei der Familie
gewesen sein es gab ja auch die ältere
Schwester Sophia und Annas jüngeren
Bruder Giuseppe und noch eine weitere
Schwester deren Namen wir aber nicht
kennen und die zum Tatzeitpunkt auch
nicht zu Hause war mit Lon verstehen
sich offenbar alle in der Familie ganz
okay obwohl sein Leben nicht ganz
unkompliziert ist er hat gerade seinen
Schulabschluss ja nachgeholt zu der Zeit
ne hatte abgebrochen weil er ja aus
schwierigen Verhältnissen gekommen ist
und zu der Zeit war er gerade dabei sein
Abschluss nachzumachen hat sich aber
auch viel mit Freunden getroffen Drogen
genommen getrunken Freunde bezeichnen
ihn auch später als ein Junge mit zwei
Gesichtern andererseits jeder hat seine
dunklen Seiten womit allerdings niemand
in der Familie oder im Freundeskreis
rechnet ist wie tief Lons Abgründe sind
zur Katastrophe kommt es im Sommer vor 5
Jahren das war der 15 Juni 2018 Leon war
häufig bei der Familie zu Besuch und er
klingelte auch an diesem Tag an der
Haustür Sophia macht die Tür auf Leon
sagt er möchte Sachen von Anna holen sie
lässt ihn rein es war wie immer sie war
pagogikstudentin 25 Jahre alt ging
wieder an ihren Schreibtisch im
Kinderzimmer um zu lernen und Leon K
ging in die Küche dort hat er sich ein
gelbes Küchenmesser aus der Schublade
genommen mit einer Klinge die rund 30 cm
lang gewesen ist ging hoch in das
Kinderzimmer von Sophia und Star auf die
junge Frau ein und das Mädchen starb
dann ist er aus dem Kinderzimmer raus
hat im Flur die Mutter angetroffen und
ist dann wie von auf die Mutter
losgegangen zurelben Zeit war der Bruder
der jüngste der Familie joseppe damals
15 Jahre alt im Badezimmer hatte
Kopfhörer im Ohr hat Musik gehört wie so
viele Jugendliche und hört auf einmal
Schreie
unvorstellbares grauen hat Einzug
gehalten im Haus dieser sympathischen
Familie die ältere Tochter liegt
blutüberströmt über ihren Uni Aufgaben
in ihrem Zimmer die Mutter wehrt sich
gegen den Freund ihrer jüngeren Tochter
Anna der gerade wie besessen auf sie
einsticht und da wird der jüngste der
Familie Sohn Giuseppe zum Helden
Giuseppe stirmt aus dem Badezimmer und
sieht im Flur wie Leon mit dem Messer
auf seine Mutter losgeht und Geistes
gegenwärtig ist er eingestritten viel
kleiner viel jünger und hat versucht
Leon K das Messer abzunehmen dabei hat
er das so beschrieben dass Lon auf sein
Hinterkopf eingestochen hat ihm selbst
dabei in den Rücken gestochen hat und er
hat die Klinge dann fastst wirklich auch
seine Hand blutig werden lassen dadurch
und hat's geschafft ihm das Messer
abzunehmen leon ist dann geflohen und
Giuseppe hat nur zu seiner Mama gesagt
die blutend am Boden liegt bitte bleib
wach dass seine Schwester tot ist wusste
er zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht hat sich dann
zum Telefon geschleppt und hat dann um
Hilfe gerufen später im Prozess als er
die Tat schilderte konnte man auch sehen
er hatte am Hinterkopf noch eine
riesengroße Narbe also er war wirklich
gezeichnet davon
hat aber sehr erwachsen gewirkt und auch
sehr deutlich sehr klar
gesprochen was für ein unfassbares
blutiges Drama wenn es etwas gibt womit
wir uns jetzt nicht lange aufhalten
müssen dann ist es die Aufklärung der
Täterschaft Leon K ist dann raus war
Blut verschmiert seine ganzen Klamotten
waren voller Blut und lief dann erstmal
so auch durch München und erst Stunden
später wurde er dann von Polizisten
gefasst und verhaftet vor dem
Landgericht München 1 beginnt im
dezember 2019 der Prozess über Leon K
schreiben die Gerichtsreporter der
Süddeutschen Zeitung Joachim kepppner
und Susi Wimmer damals auch wenn die
Staatsanwältin sich mit dem Vortrag
beeilte so dauerte es doch eine ganze
Weile 13 Seiten Anklageschrift
vorzulesen und während der gesamten Zeit
starte Leon K zu Boden als könne er so
der Wucht dieser Anklage irgendwie
entgehen die junge Frau die seit 2015
mit zusammen gewesen war hatte vor die
Beziehung zu beenden Leon K soll
daraufhin den Plan gefasst haben aus
Rache Familie B zu töten er soll auch
Jack den Mischlingshund von Familie B
mit dem Messer getötet haben die
überlebenden Angehörigen sitzen als
Nebenkläger mit steinerner Miene im Saal
was in ihnen vorgeht vermag man nur zu
ahnen K selbst wirkt wie erstarrt der
großgewachsene schlanke junge Mann
versucht nicht einmal sein Gesicht vor
den Kameras zu verbergen und auch in die
Erinnerung von bildreporterin Lena
Zander hat sich dieser Prozess
eingebrannt Angehörige Journalisten und
die Öffentlichkeit wollen wissen was zu
diesem Blutbad geführt hat was in Lyon
vorgegangen ist ich habe damals den
Prozess beobachtet und Freunde von Leon
haben auch ausgesagt dass er aufbrausend
gewesen ist er soll auch mit einem
seiner Freunde in einem Bordell gewesen
sein der Freund hat das dann der Sophia
erzählt sopia war natürlich alles andere
als begeistert die beiden waren zu dem
Zeitpunkt schon ungefähr dre Jahre ein
Paar und er soll auch Sophia gegenüber
handgreiflich geworden sein und sie hat
auch ausgesagt dass er sie mindestens
zweimal
vergewaltigte und ein halbes Jahr bevor
diese wirklich blutige Tat passierte hat
er auch versucht einen Freund mit einem
Messer zu attackieren in
Tötungsabsicht die Mutter sagt vor
Gericht aus es wird klar dass sie nicht
geahnt hat in welcher Gefahr ihre
Familie schwebte die Aussage der Mutter
war wahnsinnig bewegend ich erinnere
mich noch dran es war eine kleine
zierliche Frau die dann vor dem Richter
Platz genommen hat und auch über die
Beziehung von Leon und der Familie im
allgemeinen sprach und sagte dass er
immer ein netter und höflicher Junge
gewesen ist er habe ihr auch zuur
Begrüßung immer die Hand gegeben ihr ins
Gesicht geschaut und die waren gemeinsam
im Urlaub umso schlimmer für die Frau
was dann plötzlich vor sich geht als sie
dann gefragt wird ob sie so eine Art
Ersatzfamilie für Leon K gewesen sei hat
sie geantwortet es hat mich sehr bewegt
ja dann kommt dieser Bursche zu uns und
bringt meine Tochter um es war ein
Gänsehautmoment in der Verhandlung ich
weiß noch wie wir Kollegen dort auf
unseren Plätzen im Zuschauerraum
gesessen haben und auch Tränen in den
Augen hatten Leon K hat ja nicht nur
Sophia getötet und die Mutter und den
Bruder lebensgefährlich verletzt sondern
auch den Familienhund Jack
erstochen und als die Mutter aussagte
regte sich zum ersten Mal auch was im
Gesicht von Leon der die meiste Zeit
relativ Star entweder in die Luft oder
auf den Boden gestarrt hatte er hatte
auch Tränen in den Augen und so ging es
uns Zuschauern in dem Moment
auch das Gericht muss davon ausgehen
dass Leon die Morde schon länger geplant
hatte aber warum genau im Kern steht
offenbar die Trennung von Anna
zwischendurch ging man auch von einem
Racheakt aus weil nicht ganz klar war
waren die beiden jetzt getrennt zum
Tatzeitpunkt waren sie noch in einer
Beziehung das wurde aus den Aussagen der
beiden vor Gericht auch nicht deutlich
wenn Lon aber wegen der Trennung von
Anna wütend war warum dann die Gewalt
gegen den Rest der Familie gegen Mutter
Schwester oder Hund Jack es gibt da eine
durchaus schräge Begründung er hat viel
geschwiegen seine Aussage z.B fand auch
unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit
statt das war ja auch ein Prozess der
nach Jugendstrafrecht verhandelt wurde
er hat gesagt dass Anna und er vorhatten
Selbstmord zu begehen und damit die
Familie von Anna dieses Leid um den
Verlust der beiden nicht spüren muss
wollte er vorher die Familie umbringen
anna hat es aber vehement abgestritten
dass das nicht so gewesen ist und dass
sie davon auch nichts gewusst habe das
eindeutige Motiv ist und war lange nicht
klar vielleicht kann Leon im Rückblick
selbst nicht mehr erklären was ihn in
diesen Abgrund geführt hat er hat damit
alles zerstört was ihm wichtig war und
ihm Halt gegeben hat er war auf die
schiee Bahn geraten ein Scheidungskind
Schulabbrecher und Drogenkonsument und
dann findet er die Liebe und eine
Familie die ihn mit offenen Armen
aufnimmt aber eines Tages verspielt er
all das t mirkomann wünschte er hätte
mit jemandem reden können vielleicht war
er in einem Gedankengebäude gefangen aus
dem er einfach gar nicht mehr rauskam
oder spürte Hass den er nicht zügeln
konnte und vielleicht denkst du später
hättest du doch mit jemandem gesprochen
hättest du einen Ausweg gefunden aber
was du getan hast das kannst Du nie
wieder gut machen das Urteil ist
jedenfalls eindeutig im April 2020 wurde
Leon K von der Jugendkammer des
Landgerichts München 1 WE wegen Mordes
und versuchten Mordes zu 10 Jahren Haft
verurteilt und hat auch noch die
anschließende Sicherungsverwahrung
bekommen das heißt
[Musik]
Höchststrafe damit ist der Fall
abgeschlossen und mir hat er noch mal
gezeigt warum mich true crimfälle unter
anderem so so faszinieren weil wir hören
uns diese Fälle an um sie zu verstehen
und vielleicht Mirko um uns in einem
ähnlichen Fall selber zu schützen und
vielleicht auch um zu verzeihen oder in
einem vergleichbaren Fall vielleicht
selber eingreifen zu können also wir
hören zu in welches Elend andere
gekommen sind um im eigenen Leben
vielleicht Schlimmeres verhindern zu
können auf jeden Fall finde ich kann man
immer was über sich selbst lernen auch
in diesen Fällen da stimme ich dir auf
jeden Fall zu denn eine Erklärung zu
finden ist wie in den meisten
krimifällen schwierig und verzeihen zu
können ich glaube wenn man das überhaupt
schafft dann braucht es dafür sehr sehr
viel Zeit und Kraft
das war auf jeden Fall unser ziemlich
heftiger Fall für heute das skriipt habe
ich zusammen mit Lena Zander geschrieben
die Aufnahme habe ich auch gestaltet und
die Postproduktion macht wie immer wakew
in München und wir freuen uns auf euch
beim nächsten Fall euer Stefan und euer
mirk vielen Dank dass ihr dabei
wart die hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere Folgen rein hier warten
mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf dich
wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca Rusch
der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder die
Entführung von ursela Hermann wir hören
uns bei Tat Deutschland